la provence dans l'oeil de xavier niel
vincent bolloré bernard arnault tenté
par le figaro la presse écrite continue
de faire saliver les milliardaires une
concentration des médias débuté dans les
années 70 80
à l'époque la presse écrite va mal face
à cette crise certains hommes d'affaires
y voient un intérêt économique voici
robert hersant c'est un touche à tout
député éditeurs multi millionnaires dans
les années 80 le patron de la presse
écrite c'est lui voilà robert hersant à
la tête de son 24e journal le figaro en
1975 françois en 1976 ce dauphiné libéré
en 1983 cet homme politique rachète les
journaux à tour de bras papivore c'est
son surnom prend le contrôle d'un énième
quotidien en 1986 le progrès de lyon
c'est la question qui se pose quand même
un certain savoir aux arrêts ou est-ce
que vous allez vous arrêter
trouvez vous même la réponse
leur pire hersant ne s'arrête pas là
1986 toujours c'est le fils philippe qui
rachète lui aussi un journal en
difficultés financières l'union
quotidien basé à reims à la rédaction
l'opération ne passe pas quand on voit
comment sont en réalité démanteler les
rédactions quand on voit comment sont
regroupés les titres quand on voit
comment sont appelés à travailler les
les journalistes bien souvent dehors des
anthologies on ne peut pas être rassurés
en voyant arriver en chair sont pour ce
journaliste une question se pose celle
de la neutralité de la ligne éditoriale
car la presse écrite est parfois
utilisée comme un outil de pouvoir voir
d' influence par ses hommes d'affaires
en 2004 serge dassault s'empare de la
socpresse ce groupe de presse détient
notamment le figaro et la voix du nord
alors quand on demande aux milliardaires
s'ils n'achètent pas les journalistes
voici sa réponse non pourquoi on leur
parle et qu'on veut mais si vous n'y
arrivez pas sans être propriétaire du
groupe de presse là vous essayer d'y
arriver en étant propriétaire
faire la réponse est claire et à chaque
rachat d'un journal la question se pose
2007 bernard arnault et son groupe lvmh
s'offrent un quotidien les échos colère
des journalistes
principale question ses profits
intéressés que effectivement lvmh est
présent dans d extrêmement nombreux
secteurs on a moins de deux ans ils ont
énormément de marques est effectivement
quelle sera la crédibilité des
informations qui paraîtront dans les
échos sur ses marques bernard arnault ne
s'arrête pas là en 2015 il rachète le
parisien quotidien détenus depuis 1944
par la famille amaury un journal
populaire racheté par un géant du luxe
du côté des syndicats on grince des
dents ou on est attaché à l'adn du
journal qui est un journal populaire de
qualité et indépendants de toute
influence politique
reste à savoir si lvmh devra continuer
cette tradition éditoriale aujourd'hui
une grande partie de la presse écrite
est détenu par une infime poignée
d'hommes d'affaires fortuné parmi
lesquels françois pinault patrick drahi
arnaud lagardère ou encore xavier niel
et matthieu pigasse
[Musique]